ce sénateur, c'est ce que la
SEC a proposé et nos objectifs ici
sont bien sûr de préserver l'Internet libre et ouvert
que nous chérissons tous et de
promouvoir l'infrastructure massive et
l'investissement nécessaire pour
connecter les Américains ruraux et urbains
avec l'opportunité numérique et c'est ce
que nous explorons dans le contexte de la
procédure actuelle, le système fonctionne
encore mr.  président, vous proposez d'
annuler la frontière Internet ouverte quel est
le problème mr.  président que vous
essayez de résoudre, merci pour la question,
sénateur, je pense que l'une des préoccupations que
nous avons soulevées est que ces réglementations
pourraient freiner les
investissements dans les infrastructures, mais il n'y a aucune
preuve de cela, il y a eu des
preuves et cela fait partie  de la
raison pour laquelle nous testons cette
proposition dans le contexte de la nouvelle
réglementation proposée, certains qui ont suggéré que
la FCC devrait simplement émettre une
décision déclaratoire disant que les faits
dans la loi sont ainsi et que c'est ainsi que
cela va se passer, mais nous voulions tester
cette proposition dans le cadre d'un processus ouvert et public